what up internetians i'm dave rubin this
is the reuben report direct message it
is april 1st
2022 we live streaming on
rumbleblazetv and youtube
share subscribe tap the notification
bell and all that good stuff we're going
to be talking a little bit about elon
musk and building new things today and
then we've got a reubenreport.locals.com
community q a we got a whole bunch of of
good questions but before that i do have
an announcement to make it's an
important announcement to make it's it's
something i've been thinking about for a
while it's been sitting on me and i
didn't know when i was going to say it
or how i was going to say it
but i think this is the right time um
i just got uh triple vaxxed this morning
three shots in a row um and i've decided
to register
as a democrat and move back to
california
these were things that i've been
thinking about doing for a while and i
just did it all in one fell swoop
florida's not working out for me
i wanted the vaccine
and uh you know it's time to go back to
cali the land of freedom
it's april fool's people i couldn't even
do that that well did that even seem
remotely it wasn't it was yeah there was
really nothing there did anyone fall for
that it just felt so inauthentic and
horrible i'm never leaving florida
anyway it's april fool's i'm sure joe
biden and
jen sake and the rest of those loons
will do something that'll make you think
it's april fool's for all the wrong
reasons
but
uh we've got a great show for you before
that real quick i want to remind you
guys i'm heading out on tour the don't
burn this country book tour
orlando west palm clearwater raleigh
atlanta chicago dallas washington dc
west nyack brea oxnard san jose phoenix
and denver whole bunch of special guests
totally different show every night the
guests will do a little couple minutes
up top i'll do like a 45 or an hour talk
and then they'll do a moderated q a with
me with some of your questions we're
going to give stuff away play with the
audience
it's just different thing every night
it's going to be a blast i'm looking
forward to meeting you guys vip tickets
especially you're selling out super
quick we've added a couple more in some
of the menus because they sold out real
fast uh so jump over to davereuben.com
events and uh i hope to see you in one
of those fine cities all right before we
get to the q a i want to talk about elon
musk because he had a tweet a couple
days ago that sort of court caught fire
everything he puts out there catches
fire uh but i think he hit on something
that i've been talking about here this
sort of build new things idea so elon
musk first he put up a poll
and the poll was this it said free
speech is essential to a functioning
democracy do you believe twitter
rigorously adheres to this principle uh
it got over two million votes which is
an incredible amount of votes on a
twitter poll and uh basically 70 percent
of people said no twitter does not
adhere to the principle of free speech
now we can have all of the discussions
around twitter whether they're a private
company or not and whether they you know
the government has backed our access and
how they put their hand
on the levers when they decide who can
say what and when they can say it as i
sit here at this very moment the number
one
host in the history of cable news tucker
carlson has been suspended by twitter
for the last week or so he has no
intentions of deleting the tweet the
tweet in essence said that there are
differences biologically between men and
women he's been suspended by twitter
there's pretty much no outrage they're
not covering it obviously on any other
news channels because they love the idea
that tucker has been
silenced but obviously obviously these
big tech companies are manipulating us
in all sorts of ways we know through
algorithms and suggested videos and
sometimes showing you things in shadow
banning and all of those things but as i
always say i'm worried more about the
things that i don't know that they're
doing whether they are directing hate
towards people or in or depending on
your political opinion maybe directing
hate away from you whether they're not
showing you certain mentions or they're
always showing you certain mentions what
they're doing with bots we don't know
any of this stuff but we do know that
fundamentally twitter especially
seems to be the most corrupt
maybe it's not actually because as i
said we don't know all the things that
they're all up to but then he went a
little bit further so he retweeted his
own tweet
and he said given that twitter serves as
the de facto public town square failing
to adhere to free speech principles
fundamentally undermines democracy what
should be done and then he responded to
that and he said is a new platform
needed so you guys know i'm always
talking about parallel economies this is
why i started locals this is why we
merged with rumble this is why
we talk about needing new payment
processors this is why we talk about
states rights because we shouldn't be
just governed by one monolithic thing
that then can control companies and can
control speech and all of these things
this is also where we can have a really
really interesting discussion about what
the role of government is and should it
break up these companies should we just
let these companies fail by their own
woke policies how important is it that
you have sort of digital access to all
of these things that you have sort of
legal access to say twitter facebook
youtube etc etc i mean these things you
know nothing lasts forever companies
that were worldwide massive companies
fell 30 years later when people think
they were so ubiquitous they'd never go
away and then they do go away and you
know once the government gets involved
does it just sort of keep them does it
calcify them into the system even more
we can have all those discussions
but what i'm mostly interested in
whether we talk about you know breaking
these companies up or antitrust stuff
you know regulating them you guys know
my feelings on all this i'm not
generally for
those things there's probably some
ability for it at some level perhaps um
but what i am interested in is building
new things and a guy like elon musk
who's literally shooting a tesla out
into space who's sending us to mars
who's building underground tunnels in
cali uh someone who's genuinely changing
the world a true renaissance man a true
innovator
should he get involved in this game
probably right because we need more
voices we need more tech we need more
financial backing to all of the
alternative platforms and everything
else because as
uh has become very obvious they could
pull the plug on me this very second and
if they can do it to me they can do it
to you right you know at some point if
they're just looking around and looking
at the data
and the big tech companies or the or the
internet service providers whoever it
might be are just like you know we just
don't like what these people are
clicking too many people clicking that
scary dave rubin show too many people
clicking over at the blaze and clicking
over at the daily wire they're starting
to think for themselves and they're not
swallowing the narrative we better boot
these people
anything's possible so
more voices
more tech
more elon musk that is all i have to say
about that and now let's get to the
community q a we got a ton of great
questions this week
les says how do you keep things in
perspective and not get upset at all the
terrifying things going on in the world
well look sometimes i do get upset right
i mean you know
for the i don't know what is it once
every other show i drop the f-bomb in
here there's a lot of f-bombs being
dropped before the show with my guys and
just like the general sort of
frustration you know when we we do one
run-through of the show not in terms of
what i'm saying on the show because
that's really just all coming out of me
live
but we do go through to make sure that
the elements the videos that we're
showing the images that we're showing
the text that we're showing that we have
everything in order so we do a quick run
through of the show about 10 minutes
before we start the the live stream and
a lot of times i say to the guys you
know
show me the video for two seconds to
make sure it's in the system properly
but i can't watch nancy pelosi again i
can't listen to aoc one more time i
can't listen to ilhan omar any of these
people i can't listen to it again
it's partly also because i want it to be
as fresh as possible when we show it on
the show i want my reaction to be
authentic and real and all that stuff
but it's also that i genuinely can't
listen to these people i can't stand
them anymore they're they're horrible
and they're ruining such a beautiful
thing so i do get frustrated by some of
this stuff but my
you know a lot of it's sort of how
you're wired how you were sort of set up
to be
you know before you were here and some
of us run kind of cool some of us run
kind of hot i generally run kind of cool
i don't get that flustered by things
you know when i was doing stand-up even
in my early years in new york i liked
getting heckled because i felt that gave
me some room to play with people and and
and be in command and i think that if if
you kind of know who you are and you
know what you think you won't go
overboard crazy um you know and i
remember when when uh
i was on another network way back when
when i started it doesn't even matter
what network i remember i was on with
one of these hosts left the host and he
was screamed was always screaming and
smashing the table
and then the second they'd go to break
he'd be completely fine and he'd be like
talking about basketball or anything
else and i was like man that's just an
act it's that is all it is and you know
this this is me for better or worse uh
and also i i care about the finer things
in life honestly i care about music and
food and taking walks and enjoying
nature and all that good stuff and
living in the free state of florida
xavier says when you go to dinner with
larry elder dennis prager ron desantis
et cetera do you talk about politics or
lighter conversation topics who's the
most interesting funny or intelligent
person you've ever gone to dinner with
wow well you know it's sort of all over
the place um you know it of course you
we end up talking about politics or it's
like
it's all sort of couched within politics
i would say for the last year before we
moved to florida every time i had those
guys or many of the other people that
you know from the show over for dinner
for everyone that lived in cali it was
always about when are you leaving
and it's and then people actually did
start leaving so then the table got
smaller and then eventually we left and
now there's only a couple people left
there and they're all still considering
leaving but we just had dennis prager
and his wife over earlier this week and
you know we talk about politics but you
know we also talked about uh the fact
that david and i are having kids and
what parenting is like and
uh
you know dennis is one of his sons just
got married a few days ago and he
brought his other son david here and you
know we talk about doing shows and we
talk about you know getting some hate
and we talk about some of the love and
travel and
it's a little bit everything who's the
most interesting guest that i've ever
had over
um
you know i've been really privileged in
that sense that i've had a lot of really
smart great people over um
you know i think i think i mean it's
cliche for me to say but like you know
when i
when i go out so in in miami a couple
weeks ago when i opened for jordan
peterson here we went out to dinner and
it was david and me and tammy jordan's
wife and and jordan and we got to
connect after you know two plus years of
basically not seeing each other where
we'll email and text or take a couple
phone calls here and there but to really
sit there
you know directly across from this guy
who changed my life
changed my life
you know and and to finally
to to sit there and be like boy jordan
you know you're better and you're good
and you're great and we needed you back
and and you know he had some nice things
to say about me and my evolution and all
that uh and to see that he's happy with
tammy and back out on the road and all
that good stuff yeah that's that's
probably it
um holly says can we exchange the one
second hug for a selfie at the vip
sessions on your tour
what holly of course is referring to is
that during the vip if you buy the vip
ticket you get the meet and greet i give
a little extra talk and say hi to
everybody and i've said you know i'll do
the one second hug with people the two
second is where it starts getting weird
three seconds we're gonna have to bring
in security uh you do get a picture if
you get a vip ticket you get a picture
anyway so if you want the hug and the
picture both can be arranged if you'd
like the picture in lieu of the hug
that's okay too we leave it up to you i
believe in choice
lindsay says what does the left have to
gain
by destroying everything what is their
end goal they have kids and grandkids
that have to live with the consequences
of their actions
it's a great point and it's one of those
things where the road to hell is paved
with good intentions right i don't think
that most of these lefties most of these
woke now neo-racist
two plus two equals five boys are girls
people i don't think most of them in
their hearts have evil i think they're
deeply deeply confused
about the human condition i think
they're deeply confused about what
drives us all what i think they're
deeply confused about reality actually
what what is real and tangible in here
and so i think they think they're doing
good i think they have been so duped
by the powers that be that you you live
in america in 2022
and you think you're oppressed
it doesn't mean that everyone has
everything they want and that's not a
real thing
that's why the subtitle in the book i
have the word dystopia because these
people are always promising utopia but
it doesn't exist utopia does not exist
here and now maybe in another world but
not here but we can make it the best
world that we can make i don't think the
world has to bend to me i can just do
the best i can to hopefully create a
better world as as you guys i'm sure try
to do in your own life i think these
people think they're doing good so they
think that by ushering in equity
that they are ushering in something
better for their children
and and little do they know and maybe
some of them do
maybe some of them do i would say
actually if you take someone like jon
stewart who i went off on you know
earlier in the week because he's gone
full woke now it's like i don't think
jon stewart is is dumb i really don't i
think he's actually quite bright but
what i think has happened to someone
like him is he's gone in on the woke
thing and then once you're in you have
to keep going especially him because
he's a middle-aged white guy they will
take him out he is a middle-aged rich
white guy you are surrounded by people
who inherently think you're the enemy
but they're using you for now so he's
being used for his energy and views
although again i don't know if anyone's
watching apple tv or watching his show
really
but he's being used and he has to go on
he couldn't how could he ever say to the
wokesters guys guys guys actually
america is kind of decent actually
racism isn't the driving factor in all
of this actually there are biological
differences between guys and girls he
can't he's a hostage so you have sort of
well-intended but confused people and
then you have some hostages and then
some really bad actors and uh
and it's a match made in hell
uh nathan says hi dave excited to see
you for the first time in my native
atlanta soon as a gay conservative in
college what can i do to prevent the
radical stacey abrams from winning the
george's governor race and help keep my
great state a free one well first off
looking forward to meet nia and uh
michael malus will be uh joining me at
the atlanta style that's a big theater
too i think we got about 700 seats on
that one um as for uh
the second part
stacey abrams i mean look this is a
woman who still claims that she won the
last one right so you're not allowed to
question certain uh elections unless
you're a certain political stripe and uh
you know she's allowed to uh she lost by
about 50 000 votes she claims it was
jiggered but uh at the end of the day um
you know i guess sometimes you're
allowed to talk about it and sometimes
you're not so what do we do to stop her
you know i don't know a ton about
internal georgia politics right now but
i would say that generally speaking
um if we can find the right people that
will do what desantis is doing down here
and and fight for the right things and
just fight against the woke stuff fight
to defend children
did not be brainwashed
that kind of stuff
keep the classroom a place of education
and not a place of brainwashing if you
do some of that you'll get the parents
and if you get the parents
um you know you'll get everybody else
this is the same woman i mean she's
obese she just is
and you know she's in uh that picture
remember that picture we showed you a
couple weeks ago when she's in a
classroom all the kids are masked and
she's got her [ __ ] eating grin while
she's not masked these are not good
people they're just not that good and we
have to figure out how to how to
separate from them that's just it uh but
you go
you go the route that junkin went in
virginia you go the route that desantis
went here and i think that really is a
winning ticket
charlotte says dave do you think
people and la police just don't want to
use the word assault when it comes to
chris rock being attacked has the left
gone too far with normalizing
intolerance even in this comedian
setting yeah it's a great point well you
know first off chris rock said he didn't
want to you know press charges so that's
that's on him to decide that and it's
like do we does anyone really think that
the resolution of this should be that
will smith gets hauled off to jail
probably not but something very
dangerous did happen and it's completely
in line
with everything that we talk about here
right and i was saying literally seven
eight years ago you know if you keep
calling everyone nazis it's not what you
do to them it's what you do to yourself
if everyone you agree with is the worst
thing in the world
you you're painting yourself into a
corner intellectually spiritually in
every possible way and then these same
people will tell us that words are
violent so now jokes are violence well
if you really believe
that words are violence then you would
respond to violence in kind which is
what will smith did the same people who
will tell you that burning down a
building is not violence because it did
not harm a person will tell you that
words are violence so it's it's very
dangerous what they've done i mean
really uh think about it at a comedy
club or at any public setting where
someone is speaking if someone was to
make an off-color joke or if someone was
to just misspeak or say something silly
or stupid or say something perfectly
honest and true that was received a
different way by someone in the crowd if
we've now said to people yes you can
just get up there and hit people
that's a dangerous spot to be in
paul says why does biden continually
promise bad days ahead but never offers
any hope or solutions you know this is a
really great point because putting aside
whatever my differences are with biden
and this administration and whoever is
in charge um you know in terms of just
messaging you want an aspirational
message right like think about trump the
first time around make america great
again the reason it worked was because
it was so simple and it was like yeah
let's make this thing great again why
the hell not like it just worked right
um you know reagan when reagan ran he
was an aspirational president you didn't
have to agree with every single thing
i've come to agree over over the course
of my life to agree with most of ronald
reagan's positions um and i often do
cardio while watching old reagan
speeches which uh some people you know
listen to like edm dance music to keep
going i'm listening to you know ronald
reagan 1974 gubernatorial debates but
in any essence reagan was always talking
about the promise of america
and that's aspirational that's inspiring
that's what people want
oddly because the left has been so um
connected to
victimhood you sort of want to keep
everybody depressed because their
depression and their fear is actually
what keeps them connected to you it
keeps them thinking that they need you
so that's why biden was always was
talking about the winter of death and
despair or whatever it was and that's
why even now you know kovid's coming
back or like everything is so depressing
because he thinks oh he or what whoever
thinks oh because if the more depressed
they are the more broken they are the
more broke they are the more they will
need us and i don't need these people
and i don't want these people and i care
for leaders who uh
want to free us want to free us or
defend our freedoms about that
judiana says howdy you said yesterday
that it's time to fight back other than
canceling disney subscriptions what can
we average people do you're a powerful
voice so is your governor we're not uh
well first off you are
you are i am just one guy i am not
different than you period i'm not i
really i'm not just saying that i
honestly believe that i am one guy and
for some reason along the road to get
here i started saying what i think and
it came with a lot of hate and it came
with a lot of love and sometimes it's
really fun and sometimes it's a bit of a
headache but i'm just one guy who
decided to do what i do and then the
people that are in the studio with me
right now they're one person who said i
want to be part of something and then
they help me build this thing and then
that gets good ideas out there every
single person whether you're a housewife
uh you know raising the kids right
whether you're a single dude who's a
truck driver doing your job honestly and
forthrightly every day
whatever that's how we do it we do it by
disconnecting from them and i'm really
going to have to figure this out i think
over the next over the next year or so
um i'm not that interested in politics
in a certain sense because i don't think
that politics is the answer i don't
think it's the solution i think the
politics that is small enough to fit in
a little box that that ensures that we
have borders and basic services and
that's it that's what we want um but
it's much harder to to fight for that
position because it's not a hysterical
position it's not necessarily what's
going to generate all the clicks and
keep people enraged and all of that
stuff so one of the things that i want
to figure out with the show
is how do i empower you guys i really
mean that like if you've got a business
and you're doing something good you're
creating something good or a great
service or you're a great freaking
dentist whatever it might be i want to
help people connect with other good
people we're trying to figure out some
ways to do that
but don't think for one second that i'm
any more special than you are whatever
you are doing in your life if any of
these ideas are things that you connect
to in your life then then you're doing
something right i really mean that um
chantal says hey dave any updates on if
you'll be adding a nashville stop to the
book tour i've got my family out of
oregon and we're now happily living as
political refugees in the great state of
tennessee we'd love to see you thanks
for always speaking the truth and not
spewing propaganda i try i try so thank
you for that yes uh we absolutely are
adding nashville you know there was a
lot of uh stuff that we had to move
around because of my position on not
doing uh shows where there were going to
be mass mandates or vaccine mandates or
passports or any of that nonsense so
although they didn't have those in
nashville because of how we had to book
other things and then things got
cancelled and moved and there's still
some stuff that's up in the air yes we
will make nashville happen for sure
we're going to make austin happen for
sure i want to get to a few other places
in texas definitely
san antonio obviously houston uh we're
not doing a miami show yet west palm is
the closest show that we're doing so i
want to do more in florida of course you
know we may do some like pacific
northwest stuff but i don't know that i
really i know that there's good people
in portland a few there's probably five
left and they can come to the show but
do i really want to go to portland you
know it's also like i have to go to the
place and be around do i want to go to
seattle and visit chop i'm not really
sure uh i'm really not sure so uh so we
shall see but yes we will we will book
some more stops also the other thing is
um you know my guys wanted me to be on a
uh my guys i'm talking about my agents
and book people everything
wanted me to be on a huge long tour for
months and you know we're having kids
this summer and our life is about to
change and i'm very excited for that um
but i'm also trying to cherish the
moments that we have now we're also
trying to do a lot of work at our house
and i like doing as much stuff as i can
do myself so you know i want to be here
too for that so there you go uh mike
says what are you having for lunch today
well we just had lunch i buy lunch for
the team every day
uh i don't want to tell you the name of
the place because that might give away
uh my location uh but we found this
really healthy place that i get this
kale what do we got we got the kale we
got the chicken we got the uh what else
is in there they got the pharaoh
and uh yeah today although today i did
have a burrito
from the same place they they also do it
in burrito for him with the kale and the
pharaoh and the chicken but i've been
eating pretty well lately really try you
know get out on the road it can get
harder to eat right and you're at
airports and you know there's going to
be the chick-fil-as and the in and outs
and all that
and sometimes it's just easy to do and
sometimes it's fun to do also
so i'm really really trying to eat right
so over the next couple weeks i can at
least start the tour feeling like i'm
slim and trim and i'm feeling good and
the clothes fit right and i can be out
there and be as sharp as possible and
then we see what happens after
megan says hey dave you often talk about
your love of a good steak speaking of
food what is your favorite cut how do
you like it cooked and what seasonings
do you prefer also what wine pairing do
you like i like this question i'm a salt
pepper garlic rib by myself with
boujoulet nouveau sauce very very fancy
um
i mean generally a bone-in ribeye to me
is is the best cut of steak period you
know you're getting the most marbling
the most fat
if you can get a prime cut obviously if
you really are are spending the dough
you know if you can get wagyu like
i mean you get one that basically melts
in your mouth you know i got the big
green egg smoker so i've been smoking
all sorts of stuff so we've done you
know like 10 pound briskets that we
smoke for 14 hours i love a tri-tip also
you know the tri-tip which is thought of
as a california cut but i found a place
here
locally that i can get them and the
tri-tip you know you just slice it up
really nicely you smoke it for a couple
hours
and it's just
absolutely absolutely delicious you know
a filet is always great too
sometimes it can be like a little a
little too rich almost
so i would say a bone in ribeye is
probably the best number one um you know
because i do the smoking i i'm very soft
usually on seasoning so yeah i'm a salt
pepper and i do like i do like garlic
powder on steak also but salt pepper and
sometimes david will do like a uh like a
butter
um like a butter rosemary
sauce that we'll put on top that sort of
thing but for steaks i believe if you're
getting a good cut of meat less is more
next up
phoenix move along with the questions
bernardo says how did dinner go the
other day with dennis prager is he
buying a house next door yet so yeah i
mentioned earlier we had dennis and his
wife sue and his son uh david and his
wife over so we had three david's at the
table it was a lot of david's um i'm
really trying to get dennis to move here
um i think there's a few things that are
keeping him there look prageru is still
in los angeles um
you know i think there's some feelings
that maybe it's not fully the place for
them to be i don't think i'm speaking
out of school i think they've been
pretty honest about that um i really
want dennis to move down here i think
there's all sorts of reasons to move
down here
as dennis said when i had him on the
show a couple weeks ago and he repeated
to me at dinner the other night one of
the things that really keeps him in los
angeles you know he's got a he's got a
good community of people around him but
he although he is not a rabbi he has a
uh
sort of a makeshift synagogue that he
runs and i've gone to the high holiday
services there for the last few years
it's one of the things that's that's
helped me return to some of that
tradition
and he has that there and hundreds and
hundreds of people go for the high
holiday services and he doesn't want to
give that up now i know that there's
plenty
of jews down in florida in case you
haven't heard that there's a lot of jews
down in florida and there's a lot of
jews down in florida who are not happy
with how woke all the temples have gone
which by the way is happening across the
board i mean there's plenty of churches
that have gone woke as well
so i think there's huge opportunity for
him down here and i just know how much
happier he'd be so i'm going to keep
pushing man i'm gonna keep pushing
seven says how's clyde's training going
are the lizards and peacocks of florida
any safer
clyde has lost his mind here in florida
uh he really has the the lizards the
peacocks
bugs
big animals all over the place there's a
lot of cats in our neighborhood he's
like constantly on edge right now he's
so we are retraining him right now
because he's just on edge all the time
and also because we are our house isn't
fully furnished yet when he barks
there's this crazy echo in the house
that drives me nuts in my in my old age
of 45 years old i become very sensitive
to loud sounds i guess that just happens
to people that's a depressing part of
life you know i remember i remember when
i was in second grade having a second
grade birthday party at a roller skating
rink and uh my grandfather grandpa
already said to me uh he said the
music's too loud in here and i really
remember looking at him thinking man
you're so old like you're just so old
and now a dog barks and i'm like god
anyway uh clyde is getting retrained um
you know he also jumps on people when
they get to the door which we're really
working on and uh i can't you know we
have a lot of interesting people here
that often come dressed well i can't
have you know clyde mauling the governor
um that would not that would really not
if i lived in california anymore while
the governor that would be mine but in
florida we're trying to stay away from
that so yeah but he's good he's a good
dog and you know it's all good uh terry
says i love your tougher stance of late
how do conservatives walk that line of
behaving well but not being weak or
getting run over by the left it seems
our very nature makes it almost
impossible to compete with them ron
desantis is doing the best job of it is
that is it that hard to be an assertive
conservative that's a great question
and it's something that i think about a
lot because as i said earlier you know
i'm wired kind of cool
and i don't think that politics is
the sum totality of life so even when
things are annoying me politically
stupid bill is passed or some obvious
thing that shouldn't happen is happening
i don't think that's all what life is
about and and one of the reasons they're
all so hysterical all the time is
they've decided to make politics and and
the real politic they've made that god
they've made that the the nature of
their existence so of course you'd be
fighting all the time and you devout
righteous indignation and all of those
things and everyone who opposed you
would be a bigot in a nazi it does make
it harder there's no doubt and it might
explain
why conservatives often have trouble
conserving anything in a public sense i
think conservatives are pretty good at
it usually privately i would say
living a life that's
say within their means or within their
values and things like that and that may
just be tougher i mean maybe maybe any
of us in whatever a new sort of
right-leaning ex-lib libertarian
conservative alliance is if that is
something that can hold and that's
that's to be seen i mean i'm trying to
be one of the people that ushers it in
um maybe we're gonna have to realize
that a lot of the things that we're
fighting for are actual actually things
that we can only fight for in our own
lives and maybe not at a societal level
that you know the woke are coming
they're they're going to destroy a lot
of things and maybe we just have to let
them have those things
and the things that you want to conserve
the things that you want to believe and
protect are things that you're going to
have to do with within your life within
your family within your community
within your city within your state i
mean work you know just sort of flip it
backwards as opposed to top down this is
what we say you must behave it should be
hey this is what i believe
these are the people that i want to
surround myself with this is how i'm
going to live my life
deanna says how's your hip doing find a
local pilates studio in your area so a
couple weeks ago i don't know what
happened
i was sitting at a restaurant with a
friend my hip was aching a little bit
during the day and i got up to go to the
bathroom and i was basically limping
across the restaurant and a few people
had recognized me and said hi earlier
and then i felt that i had to go up to
them and say that i was not wounded or
anything like limping up to these people
like oh don't worry i'm okay i'm okay
anyway i went to acupuncture twice i've
done acupuncture a few times in my life
this woman just freaking needled the
hell out of my hip and kind of went it
was my right hip and then kind of went
up on the right side of my uh my spine
almost into the neck back of the head
and i did cupping you know what cupping
is that's it's like they put literally
their suction cups that they stick on
you and you get like these big welts you
kind of look like an alien uh behind you
these big bruises
um but it worked two sessions i'm good
the hip is back i'm shooting hoops in
the backyard it's all good
uh well i think that's it
i feel good about this good show friday
uh i thank you for watching uh in case
you weren't playing along yesterday this
was a pre-taped show uh because last
night
as of you watching this although for me
right this moment it is tonight uh i'm
given uh i'm the emcee at the uh prageru
gala event here in florida and i'll be
introing dennis prager and governor
desantis and it should hopefully by the
time you see this it has been a great
evening and i've posted some pictures
and it all went well i suspect it will
um and i just hope you have a great
weekend and go eat some steak and go out
there and walk your dog and
do other things that human beings do
when they're not being riled up by big
tech algorithms or the morons of
mainstream news that's what you should
do reminder you can pre-order don't burn
this country at daverubin.com
book and if you would like to join me on
tour it's davereuben.com
events uh part three of my interview
with the original wolf of wall street
jordan belfort is up right now happy
friday have a great weekend and i'll see
you monday